[Music]
people are pouring
hot maple sap onto this snow wall right
here and they're making a maple
taffy quebec is actually the largest
producer of maple syrup in the entire
world i mean come on we got the maple
leaf on the flag and
today we're making this taffy with snow
and syrup two of canada's most prized
possessions
i'm also trying poutine and cereal
covered bee retails to see which food
will come out on top
[Music]
bonjour everybody today i'm at the
carnival de quebec
which is the largest winter festival in
the entire
world and my family's actually from
montreal so i am
very excited to be here for the first
time
and try some canadian food staples
the official cache novel de quebec
brings people from all over the world to
see
intricate ice palaces it's talking
snowman mascot named bonnam
and of course it's unique canadian
dishes
first up is a canadian fan favorite that
was invented in quebec
poutine poutine is an iconic canadian
dish and is made up of french fries
covered in cheese curds and gravy legend
has it that in 1957
a trucker in quebec requested that
cheese curds be put on his french fries
it became one of the most popular dishes
in all of canada
and was named poutine which is canadian
slang for
a mess this serving of poutine is 1400
calories
and the poutine here at the cafe val is
made with canadian yukon gold potatoes
local quebec cheese curds and a dark
veal gravy
it is one of their most popular dishes
selling over 300 orders of poutine per
day
excellent
this is my first time trying poutine in
canada okay
let's do it it smells rich that gravy is
just hitting my nose
whoa i have to say this is
very decadent very rich then these
cheese curds have a subtle saltiness
i think the gravy ties it all together
it's truly its own dish and it stands
alone be a poutine in the world of
french fries you guys
the poutine is the only savory dish i'm
trying today
and i typically prefer savory over sweet
so i'm excited to see if the other two
dishes can sway my opinion
[Music]
beaver tails are basically fried dough
canadians love them so it's not really a
hidden gem to them
but for anyone outside of canada we
might not know about it
to just break it down simply it is fried
dough that's in the shape of a bee
bird tail the traditional way to serve
this is with some cinnamon sugar
but here they have a lot of other
options like fruity cereal
nutella i'm all about that fruity cereal
beaver tails were invented back in 1978
and have become one of canada's most
delicious snacks with over 120
customization options i decided to go
for the fruity cereal and frosting combo
so robert here is mainly fluent in
french and my french is very bad so
we're speaking the universal language of
food and beaver tales today
okay what's the first step here the
dough we stretch it
like this yeah more more okay
yeah whoa my beaver tail is
ugly i'm gonna start off with a brush of
butter
all right now we have the vanilla
frosting
all right so three spoonfuls of lucky
charms
strawberry jam i think this is a great
touch bring some fruitiness to it
ugh honestly the dough feels so crispy
but i can tell by the way it moves it's
going to be chewy and
soft
this is really reminiscent of funnel
cake then you have that cereal
on top it adds a crunch and the
marshmallows
it's beyond my wild streams my last stop
today is a super simple food
that may be the most simple i've ever
eaten on the show
but can it stand out to be my favorite
[Music]
our wacky snack are these maple syrup
taffy pops
this is one of the most exciting
attractions at the cafe val because they
are made
right in front of you by pouring hot
maple syrup on a wall of snow
you can roll your own taffy pop making
it a very
fun interactive snack quebec is actually
the largest producer of maple syrup in
the entire world
producing 77 of the world's supply
the syrup is harvested from a tree
called the sugar maple
which is primarily found in quebec the
maple taffy stand at the nevada
quebec sells an average of 2 000 sticks
per day
the first step is you got to get some
fresh snow
some fresh white snow put it on top and
we kind of just press it into the
counter top
take the hot maple sap and we're going
to
draw a line i feel like i might want a
little more
over in this region here let's put
our stick here all right
here we go make sure you kind of
press each time this is really fun this
is relaxing
i love how it just comes together right
before your eyes
maple taffy on a stick
my hunch is to go for it right away
let's go for it
[Music]
oh my god that's incredible i've eaten
pancakes with maple syrup probably over
a hundred times in my life
i've never had maple syrup that tastes
like this
it's like a smoky caramel-ish flavor
i love the snow crystals in this it
actually adds a little bit of texture to
it
and they melt in your mouth it's the
best taffy i've ever had because it
tastes real
this whole day was just fantastic i mean
the people
here in quebec city are so accommodating
and friendly and
my favorite part was really trying the
foods that represent their culture
i love immersing myself and other
cultures by eating what they like to eat
and staples of their cuisine
so picking a favorite it's really
difficult
right now i'm struggling between the
maple taffy and the poutine
they were both my favorite experiences
but it's hard to compare
a real gravy to a frozen
maple syrup taffy my favorite one i
guess
the winner would be the fan favorite
we're gonna go with the poutine
because i just i find that poutine is
done
so many other ways but you really have
to come to quebec and come to where it
was originated
to get the real deal it really makes a
difference
thank you guys so much for joining me
and don't forget to stay hungry
i'll see you next time